in terms of the math of the conscious
agents um we're running what uh
john maynard smith this evolutionary
game theory style
evolutionary simulations and there's
there's there's several
components to it and correct me if if if
i'm wrong and then if not we'll have you
elaborate on it
would the first component being a
category theory
and that basically being like the agents
themselves um and the
uh multi-agent reinforcement learning we
could
we could say maybe um then we have
markovian morphisms the markovian
kernels
we have the the explorations that are
happening
um we kind of called this the earlier
you were talking about like a monte
carlo tree search and a model based
reinforcement learning
um style for the agents to
explore and morph so the actual sets of
the agents
um those sets those category sets they
morph over time
um based on the experiences that the
agents undergo
and then there's a replicator equation
for procreation
so it's three so it's three things the
replicator creation procreation
and i believe you said that you don't
have the quasi-species model yet which
is for
mutation but that though that these are
kind of would you say these are kind of
the abstract components is the category
theory the markovian morphisms
the replicator equation the
quasi-species model is that
approximately
the right ballpark well certainly that's
that's true when we're doing our
um simulations just of evolution by
natural selection right so
so john maynard smith um transformed
darwin's idea into beautiful mathematics
back in the 70s and this
is called evolutionary game theory and
so in fact i used i
and my graduate students uh justin mark
and brian marion used
john maynard smith's you know
evolutionary game theory to first run
simulations
before we had the theorems we ran the
simulations just to see if it was worth
our time right you know you
you just want to see what's going to
happen before you spend your time on the
math
especially when you have limited math
talents like me so so we ran the
simulations first
and there we did find that you know
organisms that saw reality
virtual organisms in our simulations
that saw reality went extinct when they
competed against ones that
of equal complexity that saw none of
reality and were just tuned to the
fitness panel so so that's what
led me to then go to a real
mathematician chaitan prakash and pursue
the theorems now in the case of the
agent dynamics
um i'm not wedded to evolutionary game
theoretic
kind of model of the dynamics of
consciousness
i have to be open to a much wider
range of possible dynamical systems
right interesting
it's in general going to be simply some
kind of dynamics on graphs
so the general mathematical arena is
these
graphs and dynamics on grass which is
a fairly recent and quite complicated
branch of mathematics now one constraint
will be
that whatever dynamics i come up with
the conscious agents
when i project it into the headset into
space time
i need to show why it looks like we get
john maynard smith's
specific kinds of evolutionary dynamics
in the headset
right that has to come out but i don't
have to put it
in to begin with in the level of
conscious agents and that would actually
be more impressive if i had
some more general kind of dynamics or
some kind of different dynamics
uh and that then very interestingly when
i
looks like evolution by natural
selection and the evolutionary game
theoretic
so right now i'm just pursuing but
category three i think will be a big
part of it right
right now we we're using markovian
dynamics
on on graphs um
but we we're thinking that for
the bigger picture of how agents
interact and combine to form new agents
we may have to go to a category
theoretic representation that's more
general than the markovian dynamics that
we're looking at right now
so maybe um manoidal categories to begin
with
is so so so interesting so um
the so the co so conscious agent theory
the conscious agent dynamics
are occurring on graph and on
yeah that and that's kind of the them
and then the conscious agents get
ascribed
the allen conscious agent gets ascribed
a
a a category set of
of of um for example like your dna
may be in there something a lot
something like that maybe your
your your the the morphisms that that
that that
agent undergoes may be like we described
earlier this most
common morphism of drinking the water
which then
enables the agent to live another day
because they've imbibed water versus
having
the you know the rube goldberg
transcendent idea
of a business that they build uh
incessantly obsessively over five years
actually gets them a
very serious long-term fitness payoff
um so and which gives them a better
uh a better stance on the hierarchy for
in the replicator equation the gen
their genetics will mate with the better
uh partners genetics is it is it taking
in that
that level of problem
eventually of course we're going to i
mean that's what we see
in the interface right we see this kind
of evolutionary dynamics and we see
genes we see dna we see this
the replicator equation we see
reproductive success and failure um
and so those are things that that will
have to show
at least are the way from the point of
view of our our space-time
headset our interface that that's the
way this dynamics looks to us through
that
but it may be that it's that that that
point of view
deeply misses a lot yes completely
misunderstands what's really going on
with this whole realm of conscious
agents so
so i don't want to in any way restrict
my imagination
about the dynamics agents to anything
even about
sexual reproduction and fitness the
whole notion of fitness
and reaction and so forth may be only an
artifact of our headset
just like space-time space-time itself
the very structure of space-time
is an artifact of our headset it's not a
deep insight into reality
so that's the the weird thing and the
fun thing about the challenge of this
is so when when i go after this theory
of conscious agents and then you're
asking exactly the right questions to
to really expose what it means to try as
a scientist
to go to a level of a theory that goes
beyond space time right
you you have to on the one hand be
constrained
ultimately by empirical things that we
can measure inside our interface like
dna
and you know fitness and survival and so
forth
but our ideas can't be constrained
necessarily in this deeper realm
we really have to let our imagination go
and ask
the really tough question which is first
you know
what kind of deeper theory do we want to
go after so i'm going after a theory of
conscious agents in consciousness others
that have
i should mention tried to go a different
way i mean so
seth lloyd was looking for something
beyond space-time
and he proposed quantum bits and quantum
gates so so that's mathematically
precise and so
there's this just abstract world outside
of space and time with these quantum
bits and quantum gates
and he was able to show how with each
quantum
gate the action of the gate um
corresponded to
the curvature of little patch of of
relativistic space time you know
gravitational general relativistic space
time
and he could get um he could sort of
boot up general relativity
from this this deeper reality now you
could of course ask him
why in the world should it be that this
deeper reality is quantum bits and
quantum gates who ordered that
and why why why should that be the
deepest reality and we could scratch our
heads about that but
but and that's a legitimate question but
i'm just saying that once you go
and say space-time isn't fundamental
there's a lot there's
countless ways that we can go as
scientists to look
and so for me so it's a non-trivial
choice
to say i'm looking for consciousness and
my motivation was
simply because i think i'm conscious i
think you're conscious
um if i'm wrong about that and i could
be wrong about that then um
boy i'm wrong about pretty much
everything um
and so i i decided i wanted to propose a
theory in which consciousness is
fundamental
um and see if i couldn't do the hard
work of showing that space-time
emergence is just a headset to represent
all these this
this think about it as a big social
dynamics like the twitterverse
yeah so they're proposing this big
twitter verse of conscious agents
and but since it's you know like the
twitterverse there's tens of millions of
twitter users
billions of tweets what do we do is if
you can't interact with all the tweets
or the twitter users
we need a visualization tool to see
what's trending in new york
delay zoom out what's happening in the
united states what's happening in europe
what's happening in china
zoom in what is you know what is alan
tweeting right now so i should you know
a good tool would let me zoom in to just
alan zoom out to what's happening at the
whole united
united states that's what our headset is
right now my headset
is representing most of the conscious
agents with really dumb symbols like
tables and chairs and so forth not
because tables and chairs are conscious
just like if i have a in my headset i've
got something that's representing what's
trending in the united states you know
some red objects are doing something
over here in green ops it's not that
red object and green objects are
conscious or are twitters that's just
how my
interface codes the stuff because it has
to give up
but i'm not giving up so much when i
interact with you i'm actually
interacting with a specific
consciousness and you're interacting
with my consciousness and so
so our headset in many cases will just
use really
crude symbols that we call just
inanimate physical objects
that doesn't mean anything deep it just
means that our symbols are have to give
up
right there's no in this point of view
there's no fundamental distinction
between living and non-living
that's a we think it's a fundamental
distinction in reality
it's just where our interface symbols
are more or less insightful about the
conscious agents that we're interacting
with
so so there's no fundamental principle
distinction between living and
non-living and there's no way that life
just boots up from
the unconscious ingredients of our
interface so this changes the whole
the whole point of view but to get
right back to your your question what we
have to do
in this theory of conscious agents in
this dynamics
is not assume john maynard smith's
theory
we have to get it coming out as a
projection of a
deeper dynamics and so we have to ask
and this is the really fun part the
creative part for scientists
you have to ask um every theory
has certain assumptions what are and we
want
to have as few assumptions as possible
right because everything you assume
you're not explaining so right every
every time you put something into an
assumption you're saying
can't explain that so that's an
assumption so you want as few
assumptions as possible
and and so there's no theory of
everything right there is no scientific
theory of everything because
every theory has some assumptions that
will not be explained
by that theory so there's there are
theories of everything except my
assumptions
that's that's what science said we have
theories of everything except my
assumption
and of course then you get a deeper
theory which tries to explain those
assumptions but it'll have its own new
assumptions right and so science always
will have this limit that we only have
theories of everything except my
assumptions and so i so my theory of
consciousness
is no exception i will have a theory of
consciousness except my assumptions and
so my assumptions are
that there are conscious experiences
like the taste of chocolate the smell of
garlic a headache
and that those conscious experiences
can affect
other conscious experiences so they
inform
actions that affect other conscious
experiences that's
it that's i just want to say those two
things
so it's i mean so notice i'm not saying
anything about a self
or self-awareness or self-consciousness
not saying anything about memory or
learning or intelligence or
problem-solving
uh there's all these things that i'm not
saying they're not they're not part of
the kitchen sink that i'm throwing into
my theory
these are all things that i'm saying i
will have to explain
the only thing i'm going to let my self
have is two things
there are experiences and
experiences inform actions and the only
actions
are to affect other experiences that's
it
with those so that that minimal
structure my hope is to say
um i can then give you a theory in which
we build
ourselves as data structures we have we
can build theories
out of networks so this is going to be
the dynamics of graphs it's going to be
graph dynamics in which we show how to
compute
things like memory learning problem
solving intelligence and so forth
and and by the way it's a theorem from
our mathematical statement of the
assumptions i just gave you
there are experiences and they can
affect other experiences
by writing it down as markovian kernels
as we have
it's it's a trivial theorem that um
this framework is computationally
universal and what that means is
um in principle there is
no limit any theory that we could build
of learning memory problem-solving or
intelligence using computers
i can build with my theory of conscious
agents if you can do it on a computer
i can build a theory in this new
language of conscious agent
networks so that's so so i know from the
get-go that i have an adequate
but minimal set of assumptions that lets
me build all these theories i can build
a theory of learning memory problem
solving
myself and so forth out of this
the two assumptions that you made about
experience being fundamental and also
about
experiences uh impacting
each each other agents that then
impact their actions that those
are pretty fundamental
also to um ancient
spirituality perennial wisdoms around
the planet which
we'll talk about also um later
so i appreciate how you say that
there's there's many different ways to
up the source code mountain and
okay i i yeah yeah i i like that a lot
there's a lot of
um like brian keating just had stephen
wolfram and um eric weinstein on and
they were
talking about the the nature of
mathematical reality and they were
they were talking about the the hop
fibration and they were talking about
how
that vibrational data is um
is is a is a big deal and it's happening
in
that's happening infinitely far away and
then it it
the emergence of it and and um
and and to me um that
style of thinking and visualizing i
think is also important i don't know
where that
lands on on the mountain towards the
source code
um and where that would incorporate a
conscious agents
or or or if that would happen downstream
or whatnot so for
i really appreciate how there's many
different ways
up the source code mountain and that
there's different ways to
um speak about and visualize it